hey folks where we left off I was
talking about how to compute a
three-dimensional cross product between
two vectors V cross W it's this funny
thing where you write a matrix whose
second column has the coordinates of V
whose third column has the coordinates
of W but the entries of that first
column weirdly are the symbols I hat J
hat and K hat where you just pretend
like those guys are numbers for the sake
of computations then with that funky
matrix in hand you compute its
determinant if you just chug along with
those computations ignoring the
weirdness you get some constant times I
hat plus some constant times J hat plus
some constant times K hat
how specifically you think about
computing that determinant is kind of
beside the point all that really matters
here is that you'll end up with three
different numbers that are interpreted
as the coordinates of some resulting
vector
from here students are typically told to
just believe that the resulting vector
has the following geometric properties
its length equals the area of the
parallelogram defined by V and W it
points in a direction perpendicular to
both of the NW and this direction obeys
the right-hand rule in the sense that if
you point your forefinger along V and
your middle finger along W then when you
stick up your thumb it'll point in the
direction of the new vector
there are some brute-force computations
that you could do to confirm these facts
but I want to share with you a really
elegant line of reasoning it leverages a
bit of background though so for this
video I'm assuming that everybody has
watched chapter 5 on the determinant and
chapter 7 where I introduced the idea of
duality
as a quick reminder the idea of duality
is that anytime you have a linear
transformation from some space to the
number line it's associated with a
unique vector in that space in the sense
that performing the linear
transformation is the same as taking a
dot product with that vector numerically
this is because one of those
transformations is described by a matrix
with just one row where each column
tells you the number that each basis
vector lands on
and multiplying this matrix by some
vector V is computationally identical to
taking the dot product between V and the
vector you get by turning that matrix on
its side the takeaway is that whenever
you're out in the mathematical wild and
you find a linear transformation to the
number line you will be able to match it
to some vector which is called the dual
vector of that transformation so that
performing the linear transformation is
the same as taking a dot product with
that vector
the cross-product gives us a really
slick example of this process in action
it takes some effort but it's definitely
worth it what I'm going to do is define
a certain linear transformation from
three dimensions to the number line and
it will be defined in terms of the two
vectors V and W then when we associate
that transformation with its dual vector
in 3d space that dual vector is going to
be the cross product of V and W the
reason for doing this will be that
understanding that transformation is
going to make clear the connection
between the computation and the geometry
of the cross product
so to back up a bit remember in two
dimensions what it meant to compute the
2d version of the cross product when you
have two vectors V and W you put the
coordinates of V as the first column of
a matrix and the coordinates of W as the
second column of a matrix then you just
compute the determinant there's no
nonsense with basis vectors stuck in a
matrix or anything like that just an
ordinary determinant returning a number
geometrically this gives us the area of
a parallelogram spanned out by those two
vectors with the possibility of being
negative depending on the orientation of
the vectors now if you didn't already
know the 3d cross product and you're
trying to extrapolate you might imagine
that it involves taking three separate
3d vectors u V and W and making their
coordinates the columns of a three by
three matrix
then computing the determinant of that
matrix and as you know from Chapter five
geometrically this would give you the
volume of a parallelepiped spanned out
by those three vectors with the plus or
minus sign depending on the right-hand
rule orientation of those three vectors
of course you all know that this is not
the 3d cross product the actual 3d cross
product takes in two vectors and spits
out a vector it doesn't take in three
vectors and spit out a number but this
idea actually gets us really close to
what the real cross product is consider
that first vector U to be a variable say
with variable entries XY and Z while V
and W remain fixed
what we have then is a function from
three dimensions to the number line you
input some vector X Y Z and you get out
a number by taking the determinant of a
matrix whose first column is XYZ and
whose other two columns are the
coordinates of the constant vectors V
and W geometrically the meaning of this
function is that for any input vector X
Y Z you consider the parallelepiped
defined by this vector V and W then you
return its volume with a plus or minus
sign depending on orientation
now this might feel like kind of a
random thing to do I mean where does
this function come from why are we
defining it this way and I'll admit at
this stage it might kind of feel like
it's coming out of the blue but if
you're willing to go along with it and
play around with the properties that
this guy has it's the key to
understanding the cross product
one really important fact about this
function is that it's linear I'll
actually leave it to you to work through
the details of why this is true based on
properties of the determinant but once
you know that it's linear we can start
bringing in the idea of duality
once you know that it's linear you know
that there's some way to describe this
function as matrix multiplication
specifically since it's a function that
goes from three dimensions to one
dimension there will be a one by three
matrix that encodes this transformation
and the whole idea of duality is that
the special thing about transformations
from several dimensions to one dimension
is that you can turn that matrix on its
side and instead interpret the entire
transformation as the dot product with a
certain vector
what we're looking for is the special 3d
vector that I'll call P such that taking
the dot product between P and any other
vector XY Z gives the same result as
plugging in X Y Z as the first column of
a 3x3 matrix whose other two columns
have the coordinates of V and W then
computing the determinant I'll get to
the geometry of this in just a moment
but right now let's dig in and think
about what this means computationally
taking the dot product between P and XY
Z will give us something times X plus
something times y plus something times Z
where those some things are the
coordinates of P but on the right side
here when you compute the determinant
you can organize it to look like some
constant times X plus some constant
times y plus some constant times Z where
those constants involve certain
combinations of the components of V and
W so those constants those particular
combinations of the coordinates of V and
W are going to be the coordinates of the
vector P that we're looking for
but what's going on on the right here
should feel very familiar to anyone
who's actually worked through a cross
product computation collecting the
constant terms that are multiplied by X
Y and by Z like this is no different
from plugging in the symbols I hat J hat
and K hat to that first column and
seeing which coefficients aggregate on
each one of those terms
it's just that plugging in I hat J hat
and K hat is a way of signaling that we
should interpret those coefficients as
the coordinates of a vector
so what all of this is saying is that
this funky computation can be thought of
as a way to answer the following
question what vector P has the special
property that when you take a dot
product between P and some vector X Y Z
it gives the same result as plugging in
X Y Z to the first column of a matrix
whose other two columns have the
coordinates of V and W then computing
the determinant that's a bit of a
mouthful but it's an important question
to digest for this video now for the
cool part which ties all this together
with the geometric understanding of the
cross product that I introduced last
video I'm going to ask the same question
again but this time we're going to try
to answer it geometrically instead of
computationally what 3d vector P has the
special property that when you take a
dot product between P and some other
vector XYZ it gives the same result as
if you took the signed volume of a
parallelepiped defined by this vector X
Y Z along with V and W
remember the geometric interpretation of
a dot product between a vector P and
some other vector is to project that
other vector onto P then to multiply the
length of that projection by the length
of P
with that in mind let me show a certain
way to think about the volume of the
parallelepiped that we care about start
by taking the area of the parallelogram
defined by V and W then multiply it not
by the length of XYZ but by the
component of XYZ that's perpendicular to
that parallelogram
in other words the way our linear
function works on a given vector is to
project that vector onto a line that's
perpendicular to both V and W then to
multiply the length of that projection
by the area of the parallelogram spanned
by V and W but this is the same thing as
taking a dot product between X Y Z and a
vector that's perpendicular to V and W
with a length equal to the area of that
parallelogram what's more if you choose
the appropriate direction for that
vector the cases where the dot product
is negative will line up with the cases
where the right-hand rule for the
orientation of X Y Z V and W is negative
this means that we just found a vector P
so that taking a dot product between P
and some vector X Y Z is the same thing
as computing that determinant of a 3x3
matrix whose columns are XYZ the
coordinates of V and W so the answer
that we found earlier computationally
using that special notational trick must
correspond geometrically to this vector
this is the fundamental reason why the
computation and the geometric
interpretation of the cross product are
related
just to sum up what happened here I
started by defining a linear
transformation from 3d space to the
number line and it was defined in terms
of the vectors V and W then I went
through two separate ways to think about
the dual vector of this transformation
the vector such that applying the
transformation is the same thing as
taking a dot product with that vector on
the one hand a computational approach
will lead you to the trick of plugging
in the symbols I hat J hat and K hat to
the first column of a matrix and
computing the determinant but thinking
geometrically
we can deduce that this dual vector must
be perpendicular to V and W with a
length equal to the area of the
parallelogram spanned out by those two
vectors
since both of these approaches give us a
dual vector to the same transformation
they must be the same vector
so that wraps up dot products and cross
products and the next video will be a
really important concept for linear
algebra change-of-basis
you